not exactly the full dress rehearsal in terms of
an NHL roster ready there are still some decisions
to be made for both of these teams Charlie
Coyle trying to knife his way through throws
up looks for reinforcements yeah one of the best
two-way centers in my mind is pound-for-pound Mike
Pekka off the post from Coyle and there's the
first real good opportunity of the night John
feater send it deep feature a guy that has no
NHL regular season experience spent last year
his first pro season in Providence playing 61
games in the American Hockey League for a guy
who could have been playing in Michigan last year
as Capo kako beats Jeremy Swan Club side and gives
the Rangers the first Mark tonight forber with
a pinch right there you see brown jumped in he
thought he backhanded that past everybody and
that would have been the the right intentions
was there and now you got the rush and here's
the pass and the Bruins are back in numbers
I mean basically a one-on three but no one
Smothers kako here and he's able to use the
defenseman P out high for Fox Rangers power play
again yes it's preseason numbers don't mean a
whole lot oh that one pushed wide by stro but is
for6 that's not a number you want surprisingly so
there's Panera side of the net Nifty little tip
there by krier but couldn't sneak it through
Panera wrist shot off the pipe it's under
swayan in the blue pain as everybody crashes
and the whistles come somehow able to keep it
out keep your eye on panan there fake back out
to crder here's the shot and cder slides in
in front Jennifer just with a subtle screen
right there as well so good I mean paner made
probably three great decisions in a row before
that he was Shifty on The Bard halfway through
the first opportunity tonight Taco hunting for
a tip with laugh for a parked out in front now
it's Miller wheeler playing catch Miller coie
Miller wheeler into the slot for coie shot
rejected by grizzli they set up Miller again
Miller into the bumper Spot coie Shot Knocked
Down Still Alive then clear you know raer here
he has been dangerous but this is what I was
talking about kulie just banged a stick on the
I commanded the puck on that last play he said
you know what I'm open I want that puck finds
the slot here's a chance for L reier and that
one glanced off the iron before jumping out
of [Music] play Oh is is he the designated DJ in
the oh he's a real DJ he's a real DJ oh yes oh
yeses maoy Moran playing catch OS Maran straight
away harded by goodro Marian flips it over for
zaka touch down high for Maran he'll switch places
with makoy into the slot zaka on goal poster knock
in the rebound and they score osto forced it in
front for Charlie Coyle and a power play goal
even the score for Boston but you see the way
they started it and and you move it now Maran
moves over now he's in the middle of the ice you
see a one quick pass by ponut that separates the
Defenders a little bit right there and now marshan
ends up with the same spot that he started at and
there's Coyle in front of the net with a strong
stick off a great pass by poso you know panger
zaka was another player that had great movement
on the power play he comes out to support the
puck initially he's the one that makes punch
out to Center Maran for Patra Patra his shot
off of Miller Puck still there Martian digs it
free but can't Elevate the puck on the backand
just jken poked it right back to him wanted
another chance get a little more work that's
the way to get that save percentage up right
there Ryder for zanah out High minute 15 left
on the power play again four minutes in length
Fox shot deflected by tro and a hit off the top
of the net Wayman was lunging back across his
body box walks the the Line opens up ptra right
there with them get a chance to kill penalties
here I'm sure that was the message on the bench
after they were reluctant to fire a couple of Puck
get him on net 45 left on the power play Fox Back
Door San denies a [Applause] b young players
are going to look up to Him in everything he
does but he's he's a player that's lived on that
emotion as well it sometimes it does go over the
edge but that's what's got him to the level that
he's at right now going be fine line for him saw
last year with Steven stamp Co achieving Milestone
after Milestone after Milestone Brad Maran could
have one of those Seasons this year as well 53
games from a th000 10 assists from 500 28 goals
from 400 38 points from 900 so lots of Milestone
markers out there for Brad Markman yeah lots of
mths from you work really hard on it last Night
P Smite Trophy winner Stanley Cup champ with the
rival Nashville Predators for the St Louis Blues
that's going to take a while to get used to it he
loves his music yeah loves his guitar travels with
his guitar on the road Trent Frederick sers score
Matt ptra the 19-year-old making an impression in
his pre-season finale one's a little bit different
but the play was made by geeky on the board's
a little backhand pass but Frederick lifts the
stick right there that keeps the play alive that's
just strong on a stick by Frederick and now it's
a little bit of a cycle game another what a great
Ship by Tred Frederick the St Louis native I mean
just outstanding and then he finds the open man in
front of the net and look where ptra ends up going
to no one there everyone's Puck watching Jennifer
they are but like you said panger that was about
four great plays right in a row hope she turn
it back in time to see the goal no doubt about
that no doubt boy he interviewed well too at the
draft lot of teams really liked him somehow he
snuck to the 54th spot Thro coie kicked it back
on that round up line you know then year by year
by year you become one of those guys I mean it's
changing the the the fabric of leadership is is
changing in Boston and to end action here coie
stop by swayan and the puck is frozen look at
him get it up makes the play heads up good chip
pass it's a three onone one pass got Beyond two
four Checkers yeah you're right jennif and with
a lot of authority too yeah great play great
heads up play looked like he might be going to
the middle of the ice and then shurin kind of
leaned on his left side and put it off the boards
and out I like watching Jeremy San play I like
the technique I like I like the stance that he's
[Applause] got that one hammered wide of the net
by lingren nice look across by Fox osono picked it
up chipped to the slug full quiz left it there and
post couldn't finish it with lingren on his stick
and then that stop made by shesterkin Coyle's out
of the box pass intercepted by Greer Coyle trying
to turn it around offensively one-on-one against
Keandre Miller Coyle driving got to the forehand
and force stury to make a save that's a great
move right there but on that weak side but the
interception this is the burst of speed you're
talking about panger he comes in goes wide just
gets a touch of that inside positioning taking
away the eyes of San to the line there shot that
one sails past the net Fox pinching in can't quite
get there but stopped geeki from clearing geeki
Twirls around and lifts it ahead and Greer is
there the puck settles down for him he'll put
it in the empty net and the Boston Bruins are
going to walk away with a win here in their
preseason finale yeah geeky made a nice play
on the right boards right there couldn't get
it up the first time see the defensive play
here and he makes a spin here now he thinks he's
got some time cuz he does and just a high Hoyer
over everybody just before before he makes that
play to clear the Zone geeky I mean you had the
three rangers kind of got caught low they were
going towards the net and then goes the other way
you're on the ice for a reason team responsible
in the one goal lead and they get rewarded with
a goal well the next time the Rangers and Bruins
will take the ice respectively it'll be for real